jokes chairs have been a huge part of
video game seemingly forever as soon as
you feel relaxed and in control of the
situation the jump scare is brought out
to keep you on the edge of your seat and
weary of every corner
this week's video is dedicated to five
jump scares which almost known as wet
our pants as usual expect spoilers for
the following thief is a video game in
which you keep to the shadows and
stealthily try to steal things it isn't
known for being too Gary so when you
have the opportunity to spy through a
keyhole you dive right in
thanks videogames you've now made me
scared of keyholes the evil we've been
is a survival horror game which throws
freakish grotesque and downright
frightening enemies at you even in the
moment of rest fight you won't have a
too far from a joke scared what this
games are so well is follows up scary
situations with a piece of action so
while you're attempting to compose
yourself you'll have to choose between
running for your life or fighting what
would you do in this situation
[ __ ] better run outlast is yet another
first-person survival horror game
but in this one you and your trusty
camera are trying to escape a
psychiatric hospital jump scares happen
so often your heart will probably skip a
beat the first jump scare involving a
hanging cops sets the scene for this
entire game
Batman Arkham Knight is second on the
list and although it holds many darker
themes it's a game you wouldn't really
expect to be hiding behind the sofa to
avoid this scare is slightly different
from the rest on this list as it's an
unlockable in the games often in
sequence you witness the Joker being
cremated but the second time you see
this in new game+ things are a little
different
this is how it happened this is how the
Joker died
finally we've reached top spot and it's
from a cancelled game to be more precise
it's from Silent Hill PT although the
game was ultimately shelved the playable
teaser allowed us to experience a short
snippet of the games potential you are
simply trying to escape an endless
corridor which you share with lots of
creepy crawlies a bag with an unknown
entity inside and of course Lisa the
lady of the house Lisa shows up randomly
anywhere in the level but sometimes she
decides to invade your personal space
that was our first list of jump-scares
which forced us to change our underwear
have we missed the off favorite sound
off below if you've enjoyed this video
please consider subscribing thank you
very much for watching
I've been Adam and this is Playstation
grenade see you soon